reaction fox news analyst kaylee mcanany
along with former white house chief of
staff reince priebus
all right so both of you okay you serve
donald trump
now did donald trump usually
practice a speech before he gave a
speech because i attend
my sources told me it was hard to even
get him to read through a speech before
he gave this speech
am i right or is the me did he have to
practice as much as joe writes
uh no uh he did not
and you know the funny thing is as i was
thinking back on his first press
conference after 27 days
and that was a day that he just came in
that was not planned
he came into the oval office and he said
you know what i'm feeling it today let's
do a press conference say wait wait you
can't do that we gotta
hang on a second we gotta think through
this we gotta he's like no i'm feeling
it today
we're doing it today and that was the
first press conference and i we we
called the the white house staff
set up the east room put all of the
chairs out
that was that first big press conference
and he took question after question
after question but look
i think maybe biden is following one of
abraham lincoln's famous directives when
abraham lincoln said
it's better to re to remain silent and
be thought a fool
than to speak and remove all doubt so
look it's prevent defense weaken at
bernie's no risk whatever you want to
call it
that's the game they're playing and you
know at some point
you you can't hide forever you're going
to have to come out and answer the
questions
kaylee how accurate is stephen miller's
assessment to me that
he would go in the president's office
the oval office the president would
dictate a speech he would go on and on i
want this i want this or what this this
this stephen miller would go do his
thing and then in the process of writing
it stephen miller would get 10 calls
to add this this and this take that out
put this in isn't that how it went
that's exactly right and then he'd get
this speech and he had this
infamous sharpie and he would go line by
line through the speech and make further
edits there but
you're right to say this was not
something he had to practice ten times
on a teleprompter
oftentimes he wouldn't even breeze
through once on a teleprompter after his
edits
he was not afraid of questions we'd be
shouting questions at him as he was
approaching the briefing room and that
would be the extent of his preparation
because he was speaking from his heart
it was authenticity it was transparency
the diametric opposite of what you're
getting from the biden basement strategy
administration you know it's funny
because i was actually behind the scenes
do my coverage and i would see the
hardest job on the hannity show may
surprise people it's being the
teleprompter operator
i happen to be a radio host i do three
hours of unscripted radio a day
no script whatsoever not one line
written
and often i have a script but i go off
script the whole monologue the whole
night and yet thomas our prompter
operator
somehow manages to find the right place
at the right time
is that donald trump reince and what did
you think of joe biden tonight
yeah i mean that's donald trump i mean
i'd be standing in the back of a
of a of a speech or a rally and i'd be
standing there with stephen miller and
i'd be telling steve
he's off script steve he's off script
steve
and then slowly but surely he'd get
right back
on and then gabe would start scrolling
the thing look the bigger problem i
think for biden is
um it's about a speech tonight and you
hit on it in your monologue
he's based his presidency on two things
transparency which is what we were just
talking about him not doing
any press uh briefings but the other
thing was unity
and so far we've got a progressive
freight train and the fact that he
didn't even mention just a little
hat tip a crumb to the previous
administration say you know what
let's give it to them they did a good
job on on on on these
getting these shots and his vaccines put
together but he didn't do it
and that's okay that's a failure i mean
uh
and let me pick up on ryan's point guys
we only have 30 seconds katie uh kaylee
you know it could have none of this
happened under joe's watch donald trump
did all of this
reince is right i believe if he's mr
unity he could have said you know what
operation warp speed helped us a lot
but no exactly exactly and you even have
the new york times
pointing out that biden is only here
because of president trump yes the fake
news new york times
abc news said biden refuses to
acknowledge what trump has given him you
even have these
liberal media outlets acknowledging the
truth but biden can't tip his hat
although his covet advisor today went on
fox news and said
point blank i tip my hat to the trump
administration i'm grateful for what
they've given us so he won't acknowledge
it but his advisor who's pulling the
strings will
all right kaylee mcinerney reince
priebus thank you both for being with us